why is this news though she's
pissed she's holding up Ultra
spin that's the right question probably
the most right thing that you said all
day is it huge is that why like the box
is like a big as a
[Music]
room there is aan in Ontario
Canada who says she is no idea why a box
was delivered to her containing any
guesses any guesses no idea no a woman
it's from it's from Amazon so Anthrax no
what would a woman complain about so
many she just says she has no idea why
she got it she it didn't say she
complained about it like a box of books
like what's a all this reading material
like that if I get any a box of free
stuff I'd be happy it was a box of
complain something there are boxes
inside there's 30 boxes of this oh is it
something inappropriate sexually
inappropriate is it inappropriate that's
what I'm asking you I don't know but it
is sexual yeah dude they're sex toys
they're pocket [__] it's a whole
[__] 30 boxes of pocket [__] you
can't say pocket [__] on this show
Nick it's the past the first minute I
can say I know Pocket [__] Pocket [__]
Joe Knows Joe knows it's 30 button plugs
they have those on Amazon bro they sell
everything they do sell everything on
okay okay okay here's another one here's
another one it's 30 NOA
rings they're selling I what's uing
again [__] that you put in yourself
that's insane oh I remember what just 30
of them 30 of them no it's it's 30 boxes
of condoms so she got a th000 Trojan
condoms Wow Wow on accident said she has
no idea why she received them boo
condoms are whack or maybe she's like I
have no idea why I received them they
are in quotes technically in this
article yeah why is this news though
she's
pissed she's holding up Ultra
spin that's the right question proba the
most right thing that you said all day
is it huge is that why like the box is
like a big as a room how many is a th I
feel like a th condoms is like two
packets you know what I mean like a two
pack 30 boxes actually 30 boxes that's
what you're buying one pack of 500
condoms at a time yeah it's like this oh
my god dog Joe [__] a lot bro no I mean
I don't use condoms but I I would
imagine that's right I would imagine a
box at 500 and be this big I don't know
it is annoying when you buy something
small from Amazon and they put give you
a giant [__] box that's really
annoying cuz then you got to break it
down and throw it away that's just is
that two inside baseball or I'll shut up
when I think of 30 boxes though I'm
thinking like this big no they're like
this big 30 you know what I like that
happens at Amazon sometimes you're like
what the [__] is this magic like you
order something on Monday MH you order
something on Wednesday two separate
orders on Thursday your package has both
of those things in the same box true I'm
like what the
[__] [__] Amazon I thought it was going
to come in two boxes but it came in one
I'm like why did it the Monday one just
come Tuesday why did they
wait is this a restaurant where they're
like no we got to make sure all the
plates go out at the same time how they
do that they need to be like a Chinese
restaurant to just bust it out whenever
it's done that means those ones are at
like Amazon warehouse so they're already
in control of the like distribution and
then like maybe once the second order
comes in it's like oh hold that one cuz
that's the one you can get tomorrow is
the one that's you guys ever buy Amazon
things and you're like oh I hate how you
treat your employees but I love how fast
you guys work oh yeah I don't even think
about the employees D when I buy when I
buy stuff on Amazon I'll pick a product
just because I can get it in like the
next 5 hours Prime that's what that's
why you I don't even look at the other
[__] even though it's like I feel like
it's Christmas to me I I get usually
like whenever I leave for like a week
and I come back I always have like 30
Amazon packages and I'm like I don't
even remember buying all of this all of
them have thousands of condoms in I buy
stuff for like my house or like like
what what's been the latest [__] you
been buying I don't even know I just bro
30 nver Rings would be wild you don't
know because you're you're up at like
3:00 a.m. ordering this [__] I just I
just or like I just look like I have a I
have my shopping cart now 17 items for
what do you have in there uh this is
stuff to decorate I have Quest stuff um
a bookshelves books books for like
decoration yeah not read it we a going
read you got books to just put in the
Shelf like manga yeah oh I like anime
look at our
bookshelves sh you should go to book off
book yeah anime manga and all that stuff
and some for a discount I actually don't
even order off Amazon that much I
probably only place one order a month
shut up are you serious that's crazy so
what do you do for your shopping oh it's
Gio that's ordering everything I think
so see that's why I don't order off
Amazon yet she [__] buys everything
it's just hella convenient I'm a
shopaholic it's bad so you're just a
consumer's like best friend that's all
like capitalist you're a good customer
very good customer that's so this lady
she gets this Amazon oh she actually
said that her husband got an email from
Amazon saying that the contraceptors
were on the way but they assumed it was
a scam and ignored it or he ordered them
I don't know um and then when they get
this thing that's why this unique they
get the Thousand condoms and then they
they say that because they're considered
personal items she can't return them and
they have to pay for it damn which is
$670 worth of condoms wa oh [__] that's
kind of funny if it's still in its box
it should be good to go right I guess
there just a policy on like the
categorization of what it when she gets
it she's like I'm pissed and like pokes
holes in every single one oh yeah she
could do that you can't return condoms
it's like beer huh once you buy it it's
yours brother yeah I think you can't
return up what about Lube can you return
a bunch of lube that makes sense too huh
or if you're like live in Vegas those
conds going to melt outside oh yeah you
can't return those things B box of
melted condoms if you don't go home
until like 8:00 at night those things
melted for sure Vegas issues have you
had something that melted when you
ordered um I did like condom I'm kind of
I'm kind of lazy sometimes yeah so like
in my mind or maybe it's cuz I'm OCD I
have to do the things in order that my
brain planned it so I'll come home I
have my meal prep box full of food in
the box but I didn't plan to open that
box today so I have to just I just leave
it or else it's going to distract me cuz
I'm going to be like oh what's this I'll
open it I'm oh it got some chicken and I
I'll go into another whole tangent so I
have to go I just pretend like I don't
even see it and I just and it rots in
the Box I just go continue what I'm
supposed to do today cuz I'm going to
get distracted and then by tomorrow even
when you know it's perishable Goods in
hot weather well I know it comes in dry
ice but I don't know how powerful dry
ice is you got you got a couple you got
a good amount of hours but not Vegas and
then the next day I opened it and I'm
like oh [__] some of these steaks are
warm that's not good and I saved the
ones that were still
cold and then you still do a promo on
your IG stories for here's my coupon
code this was playing with fire of warm
Sticks no got some preheated steaks from
the Vegas Sun no oh that dry ice does
keep the food it's pretty strong it's
pretty strong but I also just can't get
distracted I just can't get distracted
it's going to [__] my brain up what does
Gio say to you when she finds out this
just put it inside first yeah you have
ADH yeah exactly just do that but that's
already a distraction as soon as he
touches it and gives it any attention he
goes what is this two okay this is
what's going to happen if I put it
inside if I put it inside it's going to
be one of these I'm like fine I open the
door I put it inside I'm go like this
and go do what I'm supposed to do and
I'm going to be
like and then I'm going end up [__]
getting distracted for like 4 hours yeah
how can you get distracted off of
[__] putting your food away for 4
hours dude you don't know how my brain
works I open I kind I kind of relate to
that bro I I'll open it and I'll go oh
[__] there's four chickens four steaks
you start planing out your week burgers
and I just place them nicely on the
counter I'm that looks pretty cool and
then I go to freezer hm oh [__] where
where does this fit okay this fits in
here what is that mint chip ice cream
I'm not mint chip ice
cream oh I need to clean this countertop
you know what I'm talking about oh wait
dishes I should do the dishes and he
started doing the I'm like I'm like oh
what the Trader Joe bell peppers when
was the last time I went to Trader Joe's
and then you're [__] and you're like I
should make spaghetti I'm going to make
you know what I'm going to make
spaghetti babe I'm going to make
spaghetti have you been diagnosed with
adhc yeah when I was in Middle School
yeah I feel like I have it but I don't
know how how to test it you probably got
it you probably got it there there's
those Aspergers tests that you can take
online that's like you have as you
[__] took one here I did did you did
you pass did you pass I bet you did I
thought you did say you were bored Al I
don't know yeah so I got diagnosed with
OCD and ADHD so that's the way my brain
works it's [__] so I have to like
comes hand in hand keep the steaks
outside [__]
it about to rot I mean if it works for
you yeah I don't know if it's working I
try just gotta find a method yeah the
method is
Gio yeah Gio will figure out meod is Gio
Gio saves the day can you bring the meat
in for me thank you
yeah she brings it in he still walks by
and he's
like there's no
winning
[Music]
n